[Music]
hey wisecrack Jared as always
so Ubisoft recently reached out to us
about doing something for the newly
remastered version of Assassin's Creed
rogue for ps4 and Xbox one luckily for
them we've gotten a lot of Assassin's
Creed requests over the years and
luckily for us Rogue has a unique
perspective on the eternal struggle
between the assassins and the Templars
and how it relates to the complicated
nature of freedom throughout the series
the value of freedom is placed above all
else how are we ensure freedom plug the
human race the assassins were told are
fighting the good fight against those
devious Templars who are trying to rule
the world with an iron fist
while freedom is nearly universally
celebrated in society and media quv
legally safe William Wallace knockoff
[Applause]
through its protagonist Sheikh Cormac
Assassin's Creed rogue ask an
interesting and unique question when
does freedom go too far vocalist
wisecrack edition on Assassin's Creed
rogue remastered and as always minor
spoilers ahead first a quick recap rogue
takes place around the numerically
challenged Seven Years War and somewhere
between Black Flag and Assassin's Creed
3 we follow fledgling assassins shake
Cormac a troublemaker who begins to
question the assassin Brotherhood's
methods guards Washington is dead
disappointed the sickly way that man
looks he would have been dead in a month
anyway he continues to struggle with
defending his Creed until halfway
through the game he's given an
assignment to find a piece of evening or
an ancient object said to bestow godlike
power and wisdom be careful pieces of
Eden powerful relics
when che tries to retrieve it he
triggers the infamous Lisbon earthquake
of 1755 that killed thousands a great
earthquake thousands dead he confronts
the assassins who deny culpability for
the earthquake even though they were
aware the same thing had caused the
devastating earthquake in port-au-prince
five years earlier che argues that who
are here to decide what city funds X but
the assassins say we have the
responsibility so che flees the
Brotherhood after being injured in his
escape he's nursed back to
by an elderly couple who turn out to be
Templars she is then recruited by the
Templars and sent to kill his former
assassin brethren in most Assassin's
Creed games we're told that Templars are
evil because they oppose freedom and the
assassins are good because they fight
for freedom which is best embodied in
their mantra but Assassin's Creed rogue
by showing the inner workings of both
sides explores the paradoxical nature of
freedom and the shortcomings of the
assassins belief system sure the
assassins seem noble I mean after all
you Don their mantle as you fight
against the corruption of the church and
history's other bad guys but just how
benign is the saying when you consider
the events of rogue the assassins
disposition toward absolute freedom
starts looking a bit questionable we can
best understand why through the concept
of positive freedom positive freedom is
the freedom to do something and to self
determine what that something is it's
the freedom to choose to blast weird
German techno whenever you want that's
different than negative freedom the
freedom from certain external forces
like the freedom from your roommate Brad
telling you to stop blasting weird
German techno at 2:00 a.m. or Brad
common during your stereo the problem
with unlimited freedom is that it often
comes in conflict with the rights and
freedoms of others while you may be the
master of your own fate what if your
actions limit the freedom of others what
if Brad can't be the master of his own
destiny
because he hasn't gotten any sleep after
the unceasing onslaught of Autobahn
every night until 2:00 a.m. and if you
reject any limitations on freedom from
outside interferences or negative
freedom who's gonna step in to help Brad
get some sleep if everything is
permitted then people might not agree
with when and how I want to listen to
music
the Templars address this problem of
freedom by negating it all together they
in essence don't believe in the value of
positive freedom that people can make
their own decisions or negative freedom
that they should be free from despotic
control their philosophy is essentially
that the freedom of one person will
always end up rubbing against someone
else's and so such freedom must be
restricted philosopher Isaiah Berlin
highlights one way in which the
self-determination of pause
freedom can have horrific results
freedom for Berlin can often be defined
collectively with others groups tribes
or even nations can set out to define
their own destiny and that's where
things get a little tricky since in the
name of collective freedom many have
decided to repress minority groups the
German people collectively yearned for
the freedom to determine their national
destiny but well we all know how that
turned out for certain groups in Europe
now obviously the assassins and the
Nazis are about as similar as Mozart and
Fred Durst but the assassins are willing
to sacrifice the freedom of some for the
sake of freedom for everybody if we're
all free to do whatever the hell we want
and the assassins don't mind earthquakes
killing thousands then is absolute
freedom really the ultimate good the
templars seem to understand this problem
with positive freedom with people being
their own masters so they try to
actively suppress it in the name of a
better world
what marvellous destruction captain away
from the Morrigan that should discourage
those miscreants New York is safe for
now and as rogue shows they're not as
misguided as one may think paradoxically
certain rights and freedoms can be
enhanced with a heavy hand from safe the
government or the Templars so for
instance by limiting someone's freedom
to enslave another person Klaw can in
stage a better version of freedom not
predicated on owning other humans we see
this conundrum in other Assassin's Creed
games such as Black Flag where the
British Templars crack down on the
Pirates you play as in the name of safer
seas and liberty for would be pirate
victims the Templars believe they know
best and that order can be achieved
through guidance and rule but this isn't
exactly a perfect ideology either the
total control of individuals for the
sake of greater good can lead to your
typical Big Brother dystopian nightmare
so while causing earthquakes stealing
fortunes and slitting throats is okay if
not
the polar opposite is that we should all
be thanking our masters for living under
a jackboot but hey police they're open
about it
what makes Rogue unique is that shade
distances himself from the dogmatic
belief structures that characterized the
protagonists of previous games and
embraces a rationally informed moral
choice but to che make the right choice
well to figure that out we'll need help
from one of the big dogs of the European
enlightenment Immanuel Kant during the
Enlightenment Conte formulated a way to
ground morality in reason instead of
religion or custom known as the
categorical imperative so let's see how
Shea's decision stacks up the first
formulation act only according to that
Maxim whereby you can will that it
should become a universal law sort of
boils down to do unto others so if you
want to know if killing people and then
searching their bodies for loot is moral
you should consider what will happen if
everyone follows this rule the second is
to act in such a way that you treat
humanity never merely as a means to an
end
but always at the same time as an end
this essentially means that life is the
highest value in and of itself so never
harm others or exploit them as a means
of achieving some bigger goal the final
rule says that the will of every
rational being should be thought of as a
universally legislating will this ties
the first two together and suggests that
there is a universal reason or logic
that we can all access through our own
rationality it also offers a framework
that includes a sense of freedom since
every person is capable of participating
in this kind of moral reasoning where
without the dangers of the templars of
the assassins where people become
freedom 'less pawns to their grandeur
plans even if paradoxically freedom is
part of that grander plan according to
Kant no action or morals are ethical if
they contradict these three rules so
let's see how Shea's scores against the
assassins shade defects because he
believes that by causing an earthquake
and justifying it as part of their
responsibility the assassins have done a
grave injustice this act violates the
first formulation because it implies
killing thousands for your own end which
could never be a universal ethical act
one point for chez zero for the
assassins the assassins are also saying
that those lives are CH
double sacrifices for their greater goal
a violation of the second principle
because using people as a means to an
end is a big no-no another point for che
and finally through their belief in
total freedom the assassins are
trampling on people's legislative will
by ignoring their own agency and
literally destroying their homes and
autonomous lives which contradicts Cotts
third formulation che wants no part of
it so three points for che zero for the
assassins so what can we learn from
Shay's decision that fighting for
freedom is not so simple by pursuing
their own freedom the assassins have
destroyed the freedoms of others but by
rejecting the indoctrinated philosophy
of Che could be among the few ethical
heroes of the Assassin's Creed franchise
unfortunately for che the Templars
aren't exactly model citizens either in
the name of regulating freedom for the
greater good
the Templars do plenty of deplorable
things we see them helping local people
in various places now let us use some of
that money for the good of this city and
stopping the assassins from committing
what amounts to a war crime there is an
abandoned factory nearby how did a
dangerous poison but we also see them
lie named and kill in the name of their
own Creed in the end the same sense of
moral dubiousness follows the Templars
as much as the assassins when I am
issued new recruits burdened with
regrets I tell them the surest way to
lose them with gun powder with them both
contradicting consum Peres t'v by using
people as a means to their own ends and
killing those who stand in their way
Assassin's Creed rogues more nuanced
exploration of freedom good and evil is
a welcome addition to the series Shay's
decision to betray the assassins brings
the philosophies of both factions under
scrutiny and makes the player view each
in an entirely new light was this moral
ambivalence about freedom always there
have we been playing as the bad guys all
along here's the hoping this complex
question gets explored in future
installments but until then be sure to
check out the remastered version of
Assassin's Creed rogue out now on Xbox
one and ps4 be sure to check out the
link in the description to learn more
about the game and you might be
interested in checking out this
really awesome trailer of the game
thanks again to Ubisoft for giving us
this opportunity and as always thanks
for watching guys peace
[Music]
[Music]